bueno está el momento el consejo
nacional electoral está procesando un
aproximado del 97 por ciento según se
refleja a esta hora en su portal web
a pesar que existe un 97 por ciento de
las actas escrutadas se ha dicho que
existe un empate técnico
la diferencia entre ya cooper ex y el
banquero guillermo lasso dan cuenta de
que existe un margen muy cercano en
cuanto a la diferencia de los resultados
pero ya q pérez reclama que él es el
candidato que irá en segunda vuelta por
su parte pudimos ver ayer en las
generaciones del consejo nacional
electoral en el área de totalización
donde él reclama en este momento que
existe un fraude y sus partidarios
reclaman un pronunciamiento de lo más
pronto de consejo nacional electoral